this is a production of Cornell
University
all right great well Wow
thank you very much Michelle it's
wonderful I had to pay Michelle to say
all that and even more importantly I had
to pay her even more just not safe stuff
and Bill all's I have to say to you is
WTF and I bet I better explain that
because there's some looks in the
audience like you can't say that to him
but here's a story about Bill several
years ago I was the director of Graduate
Studies when Bill was our department
chair and and we had a colleague of ours
that was supposed to do something and
then at the last minute they decided
they wouldn't do it till Bill send me an
email explaining this and and I got
rather pissed off and I fired off an
email back to Bill that was basically
three big block letters WTF with an
exclamation point a few minutes later
this bewildered Bill shows up at my door
looking at me going and I was like wow
bill you don't really understand what
that means huh and I knew you know bill
being a rather I guess bill led kind of
a secluded life from being from Nebraska
I think the worst thing I ever heard
bill say was oprand juice and so I felt
the need to clue bill in as to what WTF
met and so I said bill WTF wow that's
funny so it's okay to say WTF to bill
all right can everybody hear me I'm not
sure if I'm supposed my supposed to wear
this thing that's why I wore this tie
like a clip-on microphone it's my virus
time it'll make plant virus thighs this
is West Nile virus
still a good virus though so what I
wanted to talk to you today about is
getting client buyers as to where they
need to go and that's not only how plant
virus has moved in the plant but also
how they move from plant to plant via
their insect vector and not only that
but making sure that the virus in the
plant is truly available to the insect
vector because if it's not it's not
going to go anywhere right so bill
already kind of did this and so I'm not
gonna go through my history before but
when I did want to say to all the
students and the younger people in the
room as as I did a lot of different
things and I just want to say don't be
afraid to go out there and try different
things okay don't don't get so locked
into one little aspect of your research
that you don't get to experience other
things in life I think it's really
important to do that me so one I have to
thank my wife she is here today she came
to my PhD exit seminar and she's coming
to my Cornell exit seminar she hadn't
been anything in between I always dress
like this at seminars this is all she's
ever seen okay I really think she is my
soul mate she is my best friend I would
not have been here without her I also
want to thank these three individuals
don't smith on us not here Jason is here
and Mary Craner is here these weren't
the lab managers and Mary was a grant
manager they were my left and right
hands arms and everything else they
really made things work I had three
projects basically over my career one
being virus epidemiology and management
the other vector biology which I'm going
to talk about today and the other is
potato biology and if you really want to
learn about potato biology I have to
give another seminar in two weeks at
Geneva you're welcome to tune in for
that and there's lots of people that are
involved in this okay
I don't do the stuff you know all these
nice things and people say that about me
it's really all bad
and and you might wonder why I have a
picture of this guy and you made some of
the younger people probably don't even
know who this is this is Ronald Reagan
it was the 40th President of the United
States why do I have Ronald up there
Ronald is the reason that I'm here today
to tell you the truth
Ronald got elected in 1980 when I was
working at the environmental consulting
firm the first thing that Ronald Reagan
did was roll back all the environmental
regulations sound familiar
happening again ok I saw the writing on
the wall and said I'm gonna get the heck
out of this profession I was plenty
happy riding around in my research boat
you know eating lobster and going
fishing was a lot of fun but but when
Ronald came in environmental consulting
business went down the tubes I went back
to graduate school there's one other
thing that I learned from Ronald Reagan
Ronald Reagan was a b-grade actor who
became a politician
I think Ronald knew that he was not the
brightest bulb on the tree but he did
one thing and that was he surrounded
himself with really smart people who
made him look really good and that's
been the way I operate as well surround
yourself with all these smart people
they will make you look good ok all
right all right so enough of that
nonsense let's talk about luteal viruses
and how they move and blue do viruses do
cause some really important diseases
they cause yellow dwarf disease in
cereal crops they caused this net
necrosis and potatoes and they caused a
lot of other diseases they are
transmitted by my favorite person my
favorite thing in the world
David's favorite person I'm gonna show
you a little movie here which I did not
make this movie but but I think it's
great this sort of we understood ludia
viruses to be circulant have non
propagated viruses they are acquired
from the phloem so that a fat sticks its
pilot down into the phloem where those
viruses are floating around and it
starts sucking up virus particle
as far as virus particles get into the
digestive system of the aphid they move
through the digestive system this all
takes about 8 to 24 hours to occur they
go through the digestive system out into
the hemisphere where the blood of the
insect is circulating insects don't have
veins and arteries they just have sort
of an open circulatory system the virus
that gets out into the blood ultimately
makes its way back up to the head of the
aphid where it associates with the
accessory salivary gland which is
actually just four single cells and it
goes back through the accessory salivary
gland and then when the insects starts
feeding on another plant it spits out
things including the virus and that's
how viruses get transmitted these
viruses are retained in the athan as
soon as the aphid sucks it up it's
retained for weeks or essentially the
life of the aphid the virus is not lost
when the insect molds the other thing is
not all ingested viruses will circulate
through the aphid and that's something
to think about now when I started here
Bill Rocco was my predecessor bill left
here in 1986 and Bill left me this
experimental system which was really
cool bill spent 30 years developing this
and I was really fortunate to have him
hand this over to me this basically was
five different viruses all related all
sort of they're now species but they
used to name just strains of this virus
yellow dwarf virus with these different
ape and species and you can see this is
transmission efficiency so so Toby Anna
beanie is really efficient at
transmitting these two viruses and not
so much this and so this whole system
and thorne-smith was a technician with
Bill and then she was with me for 25
years or so Dawn was really the one to
develop this whole this is about 60
years worth of data I think this is
probably the longest biggest data set
ever but you can see that that it's
really interesting that some aphids
transmit some viruses or not others
these are all related viruses so why is
this happening and that was sort of the
basis of how I would spend the next 30
something years
right trying to figure this out now
infants if you're not familiar with
8-bits aprons are really cool it's a
female society right this is a female
and it gives birth to live young and it
will continue to do so for her whole
life and she'll give birth to lots and
lots of live young which will then grow
up and give birth to lots and lots of
live young and these are clonal right
we've maintained these aphids species
here for almost 60 years and they just
clone themselves and you get lots and
lots of a fat so tons and tons of
experimental material they're
genetically identical it's really a coal
system couldn't have done much without
it
now Fred Gil Dow was a Penn State
professor he was Mike he is my good
friend and was a wonderful colleague and
cohort through all of my career Fred was
the one who sort of figured out while he
was a student with Bill Rocco so in the
lab that I had now Fred wasn't one to
figured out how Lou do virus has moved
through the aphid and this is just a
cartoon of so this is that the stomach
of the eighth adhere the lumen of the
stomach and how viruses move through the
epithelial cells of the mid gut into the
hema seal or the blood of the insect and
it's not just a simple just uptake any
virus and it moves through it's very
specific how these things bind to
receptors move through and vesicles and
come out the other end and so viruses
can be blocked if they're not if they
can't associate with this membrane they
won't move through that's one way that
viruses don't move through the aphids
this is at the accessory salivary gland
coming through so it's in the blood and
it wants to go out into the salivary
duct so it can get spit out in the
plants and again it's very specific and
get blocked by this basal lamina or it
can get blocked in several different
steps as its heading out into the
Salford I'm okay so we knew this kind of
stuff what we didn't really understand
was how this all worked all right and
this is where we started looking at
what's the Athens contribution to this
whole thing okay and Mary you met on the
video
Cecille you you met all these three were
really key players in this looking at
understanding the genetics and total mix
of aphids and a fit virus interactions
the other nice thing about athens as
they come apart really easily great okay
you can rip the heads off athens here's
the salivary gland set up here hi
accessible here's the whole stomach
it got hindgut stomach area okay all the
parts that are good for virus
transmission come apart really easily so
it's kind of nice alright so one of the
things that mary did and this is this is
Mary here can you see then that legs not
showing him and you guys see this arrow
from Geneva no you can't see that
alright nevermind sorry about all this
and this is marina kayo who was who is
in the Department of Entomology here
Marina is excellent a the geneticist
what Mary did was take one species of
aphid that we used to use and and two
species of the virus and she had
different bio types of this Athan so
they're all the same species are just
different bio types and years a bunch of
different body types so they can look
different but they're the same exact
David but you can see here that that
these bio types over here transmit the
viruses whereas these ones over here do
not okay and as I said if it's are just
basically female society that's female
so you don't really need males but if
you change the environmental conditions
you can get a fits to produce males and
female sexual males and females okay and
that's what Mary did this whole this
whole slide and what I'm gonna tell you
is like four years worth of work okay
but what Mary did was to take this one
here which we could get males from and
she made it with this one from South
Carolina which doesn't transmit virus
she did an f1 and an f2 population that
she basically got 92 colonies of aphids
these are all clonal colonies okay so
this is the population
and and she did transmission studies to
find out whether there was any sort of
genetic segregation in this population
okay to find out whether they could
transmit these two viruses and also if
they couldn't transmit the viruses
whether it was a block at the gut or a
block at the salivary gland okay and so
I'm just going to give you the Cliff
Notes version here is the basically
transmission is a heritable trait it's
segregated for virus species
transmission okay so whether it
transmitted these two viruses there were
some clones that did some they didn't
they also segregate it for the barrier
so some were blocked at the hindgut
some were blocked at the accessory
salivary gland transmission through all
the all the analysis that I can't go
into but it was regulated by multiple
genes that were additive in effect so a
fad genes multiple eighth of genes added
have been effect and the transmission of
these two viruses was controlled by one
major gene that controlled both viruses
as well as a bunch of minor genes which
were additive which were virus specific
okay so that was that was some really
interesting stuff the next questions
that she was asking is well why can a
non vector genotype why is it unable to
transmit virus okay they ingested
similar amounts of virus they retained
similar amounts of virus over time
didn't go away and also the virus did
not degrade in the himalaya or didn't
change in the himalaya okay to become
non transmissible virus and the way is a
kind of a neat experiment the way you do
this is you feed the aphids on your
virus and then you bleed those aphids
get some of its blood out and you inject
that blood into another a fight which is
really good at transmitting that virus
and you ask the question is that fire is
still transmissible okay and that's the
way you figure out is the virus degraded
in the hemolymph
or has it changed and it didn't okay so
nothing is different between a vector
and an on vector so what's the deal so
what's the difference is there
differences in the a that buyer buyer
interactome okay well enter Michelle
okay
and Ted Tannhauser who's a proteomics
guy out at the USDA lab and Michelle
started she wanted to get into
proteomics big time and she has
obviously but she started doing this 2d
differential gel electrophoresis which
was essentially take all the proteins
and all the in the aphids the vector and
the non vector run them out on a two
dimensional gel and ask the questions
how many proteins are different in the
vector and how many proteins are
different in the non picture okay and so
all the yellow spots is the proteins
which are common to both and the green
ones are just found in the vector and
the red ones and the non vector okay so
you get you know this nice beautiful
Christmas tree effect here but the
question is you know how many of these
are really involved in transmission
right I mean there's hundreds of
differences and each of these spots is
not necessarily just one protein could
be many proteins right so what Michele
did was pairwise analysis of all the
parents both the parents and multiple
ones of the f2s that we knew were not
vectors or were vectors and whether they
if they weren't vectors whether it was a
pocket cut or the accessory salivary
gland okay
and again the cliff note version of the
results is that not only did she find
Aven proteins that were linked to
transmission but she also found buck
neuron but Mara is an endosymbiotic
bacterial endosymbiont that lives in the
aphid and supplies the infants with
essential amino acids that the a that
doesn't make as well as do other things
okay so this was really cool that we
found these bacterial proteins which
were also involved and transmission
competence and of course these proteins
lined up with a lot of different things
that's not saying that that's what they
did they just that's what they were in
the database okay
proteins were also linked to specific
transmission barriers like there was
eight of them what were related to gut
transmission of the virus there was five
of them related to the salivary gland
and really interesting is that many of
these proteins were isoform pairs so it
wasn't that the protein is missing from
an on vector or missing from a vector
it's that the proteins were slightly
different and had Michelle done anything
else beyond this to Deeja dydz gel
analysis she would have never identified
these isoforms because the protein is
present in both actors and non vectors
so this was like a really cool really
big step she got on a couple of covers
thank goodness for Kent muffler I really
miss him
he was our photographer here for a long
time but but this is really and there
was there's a lot more to this story but
I just don't have time to get into an S
Michelle at the same time that people
were working on the sort of the aphid
side of things we were also working on
the virus side of things okay and what
does the virus contribute to this whole
transmission process right how does that
work now we did most the virus work with
with potato leaf roll virus not the
cereal dwarf viruses because we didn't
have infectious clones at the time of
the cereal to work viruses but these
viruses are very similar this is the
genome of potato leaf roll virus it
looks sort of like our TV
the thing I want to point out is there's
two sub genomic RNAs that are used to
translate this sub J Omega RNA one is my
important one here and it translates the
coat proteins and the structural
proteins as long as well as a movement
protein okay and that's what I'm gonna
focus on here so looking at this piece
of the genome I'm going to focus on
these two proteins this is the coat
protein and this is the read through the
read through protein is this whole
protein right it gets read through here
at this stop codon this is the read
through domain the coat protein this
virus is an icosahedral virus okay
and so the coat protein makes up a
majority of the virus and then this read
through domain kind of sticks out on the
surface now this is not exactly what a
luteal virus looks like because Michelle
hasn't finished her work and she's got
to tell us what this actually looks like
but this is pretty close okay the
read-through domain does stick out on
surface of the virus okay but this
protein here this read-through protein
is also found as a soluble form roaming
around the plant not associated with
virus particles and so it's interesting
in a virus particle it's actually this
read-through domain is actually cut off
it's only this piece and the coat
protein which is in the fury on this
piece here is missing but this whole
thing this thing here wanders around in
the point okay so there's very owns and
then there's a soluble protein now
here's about 20 years worth of work on
this slide okay and I'm not kidding but
there's a lot of people involved in this
Kathy che was my second postdoc and
she's really a one who goddess of all
Kathy's now a senior scientist at
Monsanto and has been for a number of
years and some of you may recognize
Peter Playa Qaida's who was a professor
here before moving on to Scotland before
moving on to Korea but Peters been a
longtime collaborator on this but what
we did was buy a whole variety of
techniques a lot of mutant mutational
analysis was figure out what these
proteins do okay and it's not just what
the protein does it's actual many
domains within each piece of this
protein that actually works to do
something okay so like the very
beginning of this code protein is
involved in interactions with the RNA
inside the virus particle and the thing
the whole thing about this is that
disorder chaos okay is the key to this
whole functionality of this read-through
protein okay so at this is a sort of a
disordered piece of the protein this is
the ordered sections of the proteins
those are very stable
okay so disorder you would expect at the
Prout protein has to reach inside and
play around on the RNA that might be a
disorder and it indeed is whereas the
very own structure is going to be very
tightly conserved and that's this
section down here these domains down
here also contains several domains which
are responsible for moving this virus
through the gut of the
a fee okay and then we go through this
very disordered section here which is
actually a prolene hinge that allows
this read through domain to be kind of
flexible on the surface of the virion
then we go back into a very ordered
section of the read through domain here
which is involved in a lot of different
things from assembly of this reading
through protein into the the virus
particle itself it's involved in
translation of this read through protein
and it's involved and how this virus
moves through the gut of the agent okay
and then we go back into this really
disordered section which is this this
terminal end which is not part of the
virus particle but it is part of this
soluble protein well I think one of the
more interesting things we found and
this was by Kari Peters who was a first
a graduate student and then a postdoc
for a while was the Kerry was playing
around with with these proteins and she
noticed so if you put this this whole
protein the virus into the plant and you
look at it it causes these kinds of
symptoms in about three to four weeks
and this is a phloem limited virus so if
you look at where the virus is in the
leaf section it's always associated with
phloem bundles okay well Carrie made a
mutation where the RNA is still there
but it just doesn't translate the whole
protein right it cuts off this section
of the protein when you do that when you
not Gallade these plants you have to
wait a little bit longer about eight to
ten weeks but the symptoms changed and
when she looked at where the virus was
in the plant the virus was no longer
associated with flow it had leaked out
into mesophyll tissue okay which is
really kind of interesting this is a
flow limited virus phloem limited
viruses at the time were thought to be
flown limited because they didn't have
proteins which allowed them to move out
of the flow
okay that's this suggests something
totally different
the other interesting thing is that you
can't feed aprons on these leaves and
get transmissible virus and think about
this these aphids feed in the flow
they pick up virus from this but they
won't pick up virus here because the
virus isn't in the flow there's a lot
more virus but it's not accessible to
the aphids therefore it's not
transmissible therefore no problem right
well that was really kind of cool now my
lab runs on serendipity and laziness
sometimes okay and this is where
scientific laziness comes in the first
time so Carrie had this right this this
virus which is no longer flown limited
and she had this construct which was
completely serendipitous because during
the cold cloning process it wasn't
supposed to be like this but what had
happened is that there was a change
during the cloning and we got this weird
clone which had this deletion in it and
it actually changed that a frameshift in
it so it no longer produced this piece
of the protein okay so it did it caused
this right which we kind of expected but
Carrie being lazy
she never threw anything out all right I
guess it was like well if I have space
in the greenhouse and I keep plants
there then it will always be my space
and I don't want to give it up so I
couldn't keep my plants since he kept
them around for a couple months and she
noticed that that these plants here all
of a sudden looked like these plants
they kind of went back to the normal and
I was kind of like well that doesn't
make much sense right you must have
gotten contamination well she sequenced
these viruses and in fact this virus is
really resilient
it's self-imposed a flow restriction on
itself it changed it actually like
selected for these mutations whether it
be other deletions or in bills or other
snips which actually changed the reading
frame and brought back this piece of the
protein and when it did that on the
virus becomes foam limited again so the
virus is actually sort of selecting to
be flown limited which kind of makes
sense when you think about be the
transmission
now the other thing keep talking about
serendipity is that Yi soo who was a
postdoc working kind of with Alan Miller
who's a really good colleague out at
Iowa State Alan had discovered some
years ago that the translation of this
read-through protein was some way
controlled by some element here in the
middle of the protein which sort of went
back and connected with something at the
beginning of the protein to actually
regulate translation okay but the whole
mechanisms were not really understood
and so he took on this project and first
by doing some mutational analysis he
narrowed it down to this little section
here which is responsible for
translation of this protein and if you
look at this section it's this stem loop
RNA structure okay this is kind of neat
stem-loop structure alright and so if
you look at this so he made some
mutations in here one that would disrupt
this stem or this loop or this loop or
this loop here and made some mutations
and ask the questions that that effect
translation and indeed the mutations up
here if you disrupted this stammer this
loop you did not get translation at
fifteen days post inoculation ye being
like carry never threw anything out
either okay and so a month and a half
later he went back out to the greenhouse
to look at these plants and lo and
behold they look different they sort of
looked like wild type plants again and
when he looked at what was in these
plants first of all he sequence stuff
and and so here's the original mutant
that he made here's the wild-type and
here's the recovery and so it didn't
revert back to the wild-type and he
wouldn't really predict based on the
sequences what was happening but when
you model these sequences basically the
so the wild-type has this stem-loop
structure the mutant is disrupted in
this loop and the recovery the ones that
are in the plant doing just fine
have sort of pseudo reverted they
haven't quite reverted to the exact same
structure as this here but this mutant
and there were several others that don't
look exactly the same but in all cases
what happened was that they reverted
back so that they could produce this
little loop and when they did that then
translation on the protein was restored
well that was really neat and he has
gone on to do a lot of other neat things
with this protein but I don't have time
to talk about it because you all want to
get out of here but I'm just going to
tell you about one more serendipity
thing okay and that is what the heck
does the plant contribute to all this
stuff okay and this goes back to Carrie
and Michelle was first year and now
Stacey's involved but back in the day
care he was trying to travel to a
purified virus purifying glue do viruses
is the real bear okay you can start with
tons and tons of tissue and wind up with
little teeny amounts of virus okay
and so our transmission pronate our
transmission our purification protocol
is fairly involved and a lot of times we
add these things to buffers to do
various things whether it's to make sure
that the virus doesn't
agregate whether it's the chelate heavy
metals or to be an antioxidant we have
these different things and and so Carrie
was doing these things and she noticed
that when she when she just used buffer
that that the virus was transmitted
below okay so she got purified by her
she fed it to a that's it was
transmissible right but when she added
sodium sulphite which we add routinely
she had just forgot to add at one time
that the virus was not no longer
transmissible hame which was kind of
weird okay what then could you do all
right and we finally figured out well I
forgot to add the sodium sulphite okay
so that changed something
okay now the viruses look the same but
the difference was and here we're
looking at an electron micrographs
what's going on in the egg that gut is
that when you just use
her the virus moves through the gut into
the interior the gut you can kind of see
the little virus particles here when you
use EDTA which is another additive a
virus works just fine goes in but when
you add sodium sulphite the virus
doesn't go through the gut ok it's not
absorbed into the aphid gut so it's not
transmitted ok so what's what's going on
well come back with Michelle and the
great proteomics work that she wanted
did she wanted to do proteomics on
everything at that time right well we
shall looked at this and just a long
story short is that what she found was
that there were 20 plant proteins that
were associated with the transmissible
virus but were not associated with the
virus that wasn't transmissible
okay now I'm not going to tell you any
more about this because Michelle and
Stacy and others in her lab have gone on
to do all kinds of really cool stuff to
figure out all of these plant proteins
which are associated with the virus
complex and work in the aphids in
mysterious ways but it's not just that
virus and it's not just the Athan okay
and and I'll let Michelle invite Stacy
to come in give another seminar and she
can tell you all the great stuff oops so
I'm just gonna end with when I first
started the article biologists the
people who work on insect transmission
of viruses basically said look this is
how it works
it's either mechanical it's a flying
needle insects suck on SAP gets stuck in
their mouthparts they moved to a
different plant and they spit it out Oh
big deal right or is that the insects
get infected with this virus and then
they infect other things but that's not
how it works at all okay that's
certainly not how it works for luteal
viruses because the virus does have to
circulate through the insect but it
doesn't affect the insect right and
mechanical transmission the flying
needle whole thing that's just complete
bunk as well so I'm just going to end by
saying is that virus vector interactions
as the basis
transmission is being really naive this
is where we were 30 years ago it's all
these virus vector interactions when in
fact the virus transmission is much more
complex you have to examine all virus
vectors endosymbiont and host
interactions to fully understand how
this whole process is working reverse
genetics and mutations are great for
looking at viruses and what they do but
if you don't move forward and you start
looking at structures and you start
looking at interactions you'll never
figure it out just based on mutational
analysis alone we need to really look at
how the virus manipulates the host and
the vector to ensure its survival and
there's a lot of research going on in
that area right now Shell's involved in
that a lot of other people but this is
turning out to be really cool we need to
understand how these virus host
interactions ensure the virus vector
interactions the virus has to be in the
right place can't just be infecting the
plant anywhere it has to be in a place
that is available to the a fit or
whatever the vector is and I think that
we we don't get viruses enough credit I
think that they're far more resourceful
than we allow them or want to say they
are I think they're much smarter than
many of us perhaps so I'm going to end
there but a lot of people ask this
question well if you're gonna retire
right we my wife and I we have a house
down in the mountains of North Carolina
up in here these are the high peaks of
the East Coast many of you think the
Adirondacks oh the high peaks not even
close okay we are going to spend a lot
more time with these two little girls
these are our granddaughters I still
have some things going on with potato
industry that I will be doing this is
Grandfather Mountain grandfather
Mountain is a little under 6,000 feet
this is the mile-high bridge and
grandfather our house is somewhere right
down about there the climate in North
Carolina is not much different than it
is here so no I'm not taking the winters
and going to a warmer
I met just doesn't work that way here's
grandfather mountain in the wintertime
here's grandfather mountain in the fall
it's very beautiful down there come and
visit if you're ever down that way I'm
still going to be doing my skiing and
ski patrol so bill if you ever need a
ride down the mountain be happy to put
you in the sled give me a little rock
that's it that's all I got for you not
gonna tell you anything you know after
what Michelle told you so don't ask
those kind of questions like I said if
you want to know about potato viruses
coming two weeks any questions you Nev
uh or anywhere else be IDB and not the
other aphids well you know it depends I
mean mark is asking is one of the
species is both hopeless I pat pat I and
it's a good vector of a couple of the
BYD bees but not other ones and so we
have other vector other a bizarre
transmitter as well as Pat I maybe not
the same viruses I wish I could answer
that question you know that was sort of
the question that I was asking it's very
beginning we failed I failed okay
I mean I think we know a lot more about
what's going on but we don't we know
that there are proteins specific for
certain species of aphids that interact
with different host proteins and
different virus proteins and I suspect
that a lot of it has to do with that but
you're gonna have to talk to Michelle
because I mean essentially I have given
everything to Michelle she's she is
really moving forward with that kind of
stuff as well as a lot of other stuff
that she does but did we figure it out
no I failed
sorry that's why I'm leaving yes mutants
that are enabled
right well we made we made the mutants
had made of a mouse
right right well that's a good that's a
good question because the Selective
pressure is in the absence of a
transmission so it's not just that
there's you know that they're reverting
so they can be transmitted they're
reverting for something else and they're
reverting to be back in the phone why
why do they do that I don't know I mean
they seem to replicate just fine in
mesophyll cells right anybody can do it
pro to fly us in the room you know so
there doesn't seem to be a reason why
they don't like visible cells but for
some reason they select for those sued
over Burton's you know an interview you
know going back to the literature
there's a lot of pseudo reversions that
people have found in terms of a
transmission you know not necessarily
looking at other thank you so a pseudo
reversion is like a real you know comes
up again and again and again with these
viruses but I don't know what the
selection question is it's a great
question
Michelle figure that sort of you know
it's at work on that that we published
and that's coming out but there's a big
you know defense response and muzychko
was signaling from the chloroplast and
so you know one possibility is that in
the poem they're sort of buffered from
from you know frost pathways and that
sort of thing so you have any sense what
the mutations that's a great question so
the question is what's the mutation rate
in these viruses well they're RNA
viruses so right so theoretically it
should be about one mutation for every
replication cycle but I don't know I
mean I'm not so sure that I believe in
that anymore and I say that only because
I work on T V Y where we had done a lot
of that kind of work and we don't see
the level of genetic diversity within a
population that we
would expect to see so I don't know I
mean there there is quite a bit of
literature now in luteal viruses where
there are a lot of recombinants
occurring but I don't know we don't we
have a lot of data I mean I did an
experiment where he did have a mutation
but it was still a wild phenotype and
that one didn't refer you didn't see any
changes in that but his mutants where
something happened like there was low
titer or they moved out then you get the
reverse so it's not like it's just
making random mutations overnight it's
like there has to be some kind of
selection yeah yeah that's another
reason why I'm leaving because I see I
can't remember is there any evidence for
a proteins associating with the virus on
the way out being important for
establishing actually plants wow that's
a great question we we've not looked at
that it's not that be tough to try and
figure out I mean there's so little
virus transferred to a plant it'd be
really really hard to do that now you
know it's interesting because there is
quite a bit of work going on especially
in the animal viruses where the the
vector is creating an infection site or
the virus in the host you know and
that's that's sort of injecting a lot of
vectors proteins into that site where it
also dumps the virus in it and it helps
the virus then create an infection site
we haven't been able to do that with
would these viruses you know could we
just we can't get enough material but
it's really interesting and I suspect
that there is something there like a
parlous from Lee said there was a part
of protein that was
structure that was important in
transcription written earlier part of a
protein and then she said that when
you've mutated and Stanley knocked it
out it reverted back to a similar kind
of stem instructor right do you have any
inferences mechanism will I be the RNA
backbone stemming structures are
important for its ability to perform
transcription its translation its
translation sorry they said
transcription but yeah we don't really
know stem loop structures and viruses
are a fairly common structure that's
involved in function but why that is we
know that that structure loops back
we've done the work to show where it
loops back and finds just prior to the
start of that ORF so it is sort of a
binding thing but why that particular
stem loop structure is so important we
don't know other than it is we have lots
of mutants that you know it kind of
disrupt that one and it always comes
back to building some sort of stem loop
structures not always the same one but
similar similar enough so it's certainly
not just a you know linear sort of
binding you know linear sequence binding
to another linear sequence it has
something to do with that stem-loop
structure in RNA if we don't understand
change interactions with the ribosomes
good yeah it might be you know because a
lot of yeah you're looking at you know
like T RNAs and things like that those
are all very similar structures like
that kind of stem looping structures so
yeah it could very well be something
like that
one last question for general question
what advantage is it to the vector to be
carrying viruses around Wow well we used
to think none but I don't think that
that's true anymore Michelle you want to
genny's he's that Jenny is working on
that kind of stuff and and there's a lot
to it
you know it's yeah we used to think it
doesn't make any difference at all but
it does you know in terms of and and you
know there's there's all this function
of virus sort of manipulating behavior
you know to make sure that the aphid
either stays on the plant or doesn't
stay on the plant depending on what kind
of virus it is whether it wants to be
transmitted quickly or takes a long time
so there's all this kind of really neat
stuff that's coming in that yeah you're
gonna have to wait for all of Michelle's
people to start giving seminars because
they got some really cool stuff come on
so it sounds like there's lots more to
come let's think not just for today's
seminar seems like a great colleague
mentor this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu